[Music]
uh chantelle is with us in houston texas
good afternoon chantel how can we help
hey good afternoon um thank you for
having me i'm a huge fan of yours and
the dave's show
um so i'm gonna try to keep it concise
for you okay
i'm 33 year old woman i live in houston
i
am i'm single and i'm a
i'm a full-time teacher i make uh 56
for um i do uber sometime on the side
and i have a health coaching business
that i've um
started that i i'm not currently making
any money in but
i'm i'm working on it and
i feel like i've been budgeting i've
been doing the things but i'm not
saving anymore and i'm not um and i'm
not paying any extra towards my debt
because i feel like i'm
really just getting by um
and so i'm trying to find ways to reduce
my debt right now because it's really
making me feel like
a little desperate i do want to be debt
free and i feel like unless i
it's just a lot of stress around like
trying to grow a business that's not
making any money
and trying to find ways to hustle to pay
off this debt without taking away from
that
and so i came up with the idea yesterday
of what if i sold my
vehicle i have a i have about 80 000
in debt okay um twenty thousand
nine hundred comes from the vehicle um
sixty five hundred comes from consumer
debt which were investments that i made
in coaches to help me grow my business
and the rest of student loans um
the vehicle itself has about it's
worth about fourteen thousand dollars
but being a dumb kid
in my twenties and rolling over into my
thirties i've rolled over
my old debt into a new vehicle and so
i'm negative
in that vehicle and so
what i thought about doing is going to a
dealership
and trading it in for a used
used car um to lower
the actual debt so it's all in with the
negative equity
and the car payment being under ten
thousand dollars i feel like i would be
able to get rid of that
sooner than the two years that it would
take to pay it off
yeah but what you're going to do is just
roll over that negative equity as well
though
into that uh so i think what we got to
do is just step
back and reassess the entire financial
situation
so you make fifty six thousand four
hundred dollars a year
right yeah yeah uh when you do uber
like if you were to get hyper
intentional uh how much
extra can you make a month ubering
well i just started that back um because
i was really relying on my business
growing
um but if i wanted to
really go full time into doing that
especially being offered a summer i
could add about another
thousand or so um
safely yeah a month probably even more
i mean if yeah i was gonna say you can
do a little bit more than that
well yeah but you know in my mind i'm
also thinking it costs for gas it costs
for all that stuff so even though you
make money you also
lose it by having to replace the gas and
stuff like that but yes i could probably
do about 2 000 extra
a month okay 2 000 extra month right
there all right
during the summer for sure yeah and then
you got your school teacher so i
definitely appreciate your service and
helping our young people thank you
yeah for sure um now okay so we got two
thousand dollars extra month that we can
get right there right
um so that'll bring you up to right
around like 70.
and then you have seven thousand dollars
in debt twenty thousand dollars nine
hundred dollars in a car what kind of
car is it
it's a 2018 jeep cherokee um
you got a lot of miles on it it's only
35 000 miles on it
um yeah but you wrote in a lot of
negative equity
about six grand and so that i'm actually
in the car max bathroom because i was
gonna go get it
appraised to see if i could go trade it
in for something lower because i feel
like if i had
a lower like wait overall are you at
carmax right now
when we get off the phone listen listen
here shantel you're gonna walk
straight out walk right past the
salesman okay
i will tell you that right now but you
know i i need to hear you clearly so i'm
going to say right there this is dope i
like this i'm talking to her in the
bathroom this one i'm talking about
she's serious about this lifestyle i
gotta talk to anthony i need to get out
of debt that's right girl you stay right
there in the bathroom
i do i need to get out of bed all right
so let's do this all right how much
money do you have
in your savings account right now um
1500.
okay 1500 okay you're gonna keep that
and you're gonna keep that in your
savings account right now all right
um so you have you have a couple of
options you have some options here
um right now what you got to figure out
is that car that car
is a huge problem so i would not suggest
trading it in and then stacking on more
debt
what i would advise you to do is sell
the car
okay and then whatever you can sell the
car for
then go take out a personal loan for the
difference
now listen what i'm saying here is if
you can sell the car
for 16 000 then what i'm saying is go
get a loan for 4 500 bucks
to to do the difference or whatever that
math is so you go down from 20
900 in debt to only 5 000 in debt now
the problem is going to be
that you need to pay cash for a used
car this means that you're not going to
be able to drive a car max car
because you're going to drive past
carmax when you get off the phone with
me okay yes
right so so that's what i would
recommend is go back to kelly blue book
see what you can privately sell the car
for and then whatever they say
private sell is you sell it for that
then i am okay with you going to get a
personal loan
to replace the difference okay and then
that goes inside of your debt snowball
but then the next thing is you're gonna
need to use your emergency fund
to go ahead and buy you a cash car
and i'm talking about here a chantel you
need to be spending right around
two to three grand to get you a cash
car okay so this means that you may need
to keep your car
um so you can get a little bit more
money up to get a little bit more money
up to go buy a cash card
but that's the first process do not
trade this in
because a car salesman is going to talk
you into something that's not going to
be a wise move for you
all right okay then from there you're
just going to take the debt snowball
method you're going to line up all your
debt from smallest to largest
make all your minimum payments you're
going to be out there ubering
chantal like you're going to be out
there ubering from sun up to sun down
you are 33 years old you're single you
have any kids
no yeah so right now you have no kids
right now you have no kids
you have no friends you have no
boyfriend you don't have
nothing you don't have time for nothing
right now the
next two years is about you getting
out of debt if a man come into your life
chantelle
and and he talking about i wanna do this
no if he ain't helping you get towards
your goals
you don't have time for all right bottom
line
so this is what i want you to do i want
you to stay on the line i'm gonna have
kelly give you access to
ramsey plus okay the very first thing i
want you to want to go sign up for that
and take
our classes okay i want you to sit down
with this get connected with our
community
then the next thing you're gonna do is
you're gonna go home and figure out how
can you sell this car
and what kind of car can you get for
right around two grand twenty five
hundred dollars
then after that you're gonna go back
onto youtube
okay and you're gonna subscribe to my
channel and i'm gonna walk you through
this journey
okay now get out of carmax get out of
the bathroom
go straight to your car get in your car
go home
okay go home connect with us we're going
to walk you through this process
i'm giving you this ramsey plus for free
on me
because i want to help you turn your
life around america this is what it's
about man this is what it's about
call me in the bathroom that's what i'm
talking about
that's when i know you intentional about
getting out of debt
this is the ramsay show